you are about to watch the july 2022
titled arena as you can probably tell by
the title it was one of my best
performances of recent memory
um it started off kind of slowly i i
lost uh the first few games but then i i
went on a really hot streak and i think
you'll enjoy the games hopefully learn a
thing or two along the way
and uh be sure to leave a comment below
what your favorite game is throughout
the video i'll have everything time
stamped so i do hope you enjoy
and before we get to the chest i do want
to thank the sponsor of today's video
which is audible so if you haven't heard
of audible which you probably should buy
now they are a massive platform of
audiobooks and everything spoken word
entertainment and i've been using them
long before they've sponsored my content
i love binging audiobooks wherever i go
whether i'm taking walks in the shower
traveling before i fall asleep it's a
great way to stay entertained and also
continue the journey of learning and
improving uh all areas of my life
so i want to give a sneak peek into my
audible library and just share some
titles i've listened to recently one
audiobook i'd like to recommend
is
called this is an audiobook by one of my
favorite comedians demetri martin
and this is kind of a difficult work to
describe but it's super witty and funny
has a lot of like dry humor and a lot of
sophisticated humor that i think a lot
of my viewers would really enjoy
and it's basically a few hours of just
pure comedy and i can't tell you how
many times i was laughing out loud when
listening to this book
so if you would like to try audible for
free and get a free audiobook of your
choice including this is an audiobook i
do have a special offer for my viewers
if you click the link in the video
description or text i am rosen to 500
500 you can get a free audiobook of your
choice 30 day free trial to audible and
i really hope it brings you as much
value as it's brought to me
and uh and yeah let me know what you get
and let's get back to the chess
okay
so tylerina begins
i feel decently warmed up
playing vladimir baichkov
i'm gonna play something a little bit
new i'm gonna play bishop d6
it's a new repertoire thing for me
and then
the idea is to take and play e5
this is a super rare line but i studied
it a little bit and it looks playable
and avoids like the typical
[Music]
catalan structures i mean white might be
still annoying me i might be slightly
worse here
but it splits
probably have to take that
take and undevelop
and then later redevelop
i mean white has more space but now at
least this bishop is kind of shut out or
shut in
and then i can find a new home maybe
oh no my pawn swinging the im not a gm
oh thanks so much adrian chess
so if queen takes pawn i uh skewer and
win the bishop
meanwhile probably knight c5
maybe f6 at some point too
looks reasonable
some eventual b6
b6 right away
there's a tricky trap if knight d2 i
have bishop e2
g4 might be coming
i'd like to strike with h5 at some point
okay no bishop e2 for me
that's getting interesting though
takes
um
and
so i just want to get the bishop to c5
but not super simple
f6 first
allowing takes but then the night solid
i have to watch out for my queen getting
trapped
wow
okay so doing some reorganizing of the
minor pieces
finding this
and this actually looks really good for
me now
because this is coming in this is coming
in
if i take
um
[Music]
not quite seeing it
getting low on time
oh no
i i had to sack the queen i'm just
losing now
i'm in the fight
14 seconds left
not looking good
i really liked the position until
everything crumbled
it's cool opening too
what did i miss i mean vlog's better
here
bishop okay so i played knight before
apparently it was completely winning if
i go into this line yeah first i was
hesitant to play c6
but i always have bishop f7
yeah i had to open the position sooner
the king on e3
what to do
okay still feels like a warm-up
uh let's run a prediction
um
what place will
eric finish
top
i'm going to give a few options
top 30.
okay
let's do 31 through 50
50 through 100
or 100
one 101 to 150
151 plus
okay we're making a 10 minute prediction
starting now
i hope i did that right
i think i did
i played this move
e5 is maybe coming
this makes some sense
so black can't easily castle
[Music]
but black can easily start trying to
attack me
i might have to play queen d2 here
not the most pleasant move
good luck with the the tournament
i was really annoying
thank you phoenix
this will be a decently long tournament
so losing the first game
plenty of time to come back
it feels like i beserked this game even
though
uh
i just took a long time in the opening
so i want to castle and play king h1
i think i can afford to castle into the
pin
[Music]
was maybe rook d1 first
ensuring the knights defended
i don't think black can take the pawn
if you're here here
i should like king h2
[Music]
this move could be annoying
[Music]
so preventing knight g3 i mean g4 might
come
maybe this is all part of the plan
knife six queen h6
wow
very clever
i think i have to take
i have rook h1 here
and takes
it's looking shaky
but the minor pieces for black are kind
of out of it i'm just kind of scared of
the
f5 move eventually
okay
we trade
f5 still may be coming
i want to take on a on c4 but
let's start with rook a5
time is not good
yeah i was getting outplayed final
position i might actually be okay though
uh what to do
first first two games
have to treat as a warm-up
um
prediction's still going
most people think i'll finish in
between 51 and 100.
yeah time management was not good that
game i mean i took some time at the
beginning making the polls so
okay try and recover
playing alex r who i played before
um
okay play uh against the king's gambit
queenie2
[Music]
a new move for me i think i can take
some sort of opening crap
wow
this is very new for me
might be walking straight into
preparation but
it looks reasonable because i have f6
i'm gonna try and win the pawn
[Music]
i could even play knight c6 here first
and there is bishop e3
i'm down upon but
life goes on
oh thank you hbozy
yeah i'm looking forward to
i think i can take this now
g2 is attacked
um
some options here
knight d4 c3
knight c2
[Music]
i might start with this actually
i'm trying to create some weakness like
if c3 knight t3
knife three is coming
i have knight c1 to try and win the pawn
[Music]
kind of like this move though
trying to win the b pawn
rook d2 rookie one king g2
okay sorry with this
one legal move
i'm not sure what white was thinking
about
question is what to do here though
and just this
and 92 is coming
or that move
rookie three
what was you thinking about
okay i want to play this and this
hmm
so if rook c2 i play rookie 3 i think
i'm winning a pawn
still very tricky though
king is a bit stuck now
okay wow wife just resigns
i would have fought on there
but i was winning uh upon
is the stream dropping i don't think
there were any drop frames in a while
but
oh maybe there were sorry about that
i'll try and close as many tabs as i can
[Music]
yeah hopefully it improves
okay top 200 after one win
we have a
whatever this
i is 92 is like the main move
how many times do i normally have open
usually just twitch chat um i did have
some chess tabs open like from the levy
game
but really not too much
play h4
and queen d2 first
black is tempting me
i think i'll play h4
no need to take the knight
plus and space advantage
okay now it's really tempting to
[Music]
take on a6
but i'm not in so much rush
okay f5 is the plan
[Music]
h5 might be played
how to do this
e6 takes [ __ ] by four bit by four right
away
hmm
i might be missing something obvious
here but
i'm not seeing it
knight c5
knight c5
hmm
spending too much time as well
i wasn't seeing it
okay let's go full ham
looks ridiculous to castle i just wanted
to connect the rooks
a5 may be coming soon
ah that doesn't quite work
uh
way too slow that game
what to do
that was the wrong type of ham
it was like a slow cooked ham
i had to
put the setting on broil or something
okay one goal for this game just to stay
off stay up on time and not overthink
things
already getting a pleasant opening
[Music]
and this is something i've had
a decent amount before
black has lost casting rights
e5 might come at some point
that could be a positional struggle
[Music]
a3 b4
yeah i think like so far the positions
i'm getting aren't so bad it's just just
time management
have to avoid the tilt as well
[Music]
go for some kind of uh
maybe f4 as a main break
interesting
h4
ideally i'd like to get in queen g5
to threaten this move but okay not
happening
okay now f4 looks
it looks sharp
allowing takes we trade 95 in the end
but then rook f1
bishop's not so impressive but it does
hold together the
structure some knight d5 potential
[Music]
also some triple battery potential
okay so there's three different targets
um d4 is like the main
concern for lac
we might see rook d7
and then the question is how do i build
up more pressure
now it's super simple
maybe i start with some like
prophylactic king h1
[Music]
like i don't want to be overthinking
here i just wanna
keep the game going
it's not so clear what black is doing
[Music]
uh rook f6
might swing over
there is a plan to eventually trade
queens
wondering if i can take in bishop c4
but this
plan realizing bishop c4 is kind of a
cool idea it doesn't work anymore though
oh but this is a free pawn
yeah this is a much cleaner game
i'm going to try and keep it clean
let's f5
and why not
queen f2 and go after the pawn
these pawns are still targets
i take that
take an e5 in the end
i think it works
calculate
e5
which i'm not seeing the clear win
and there's no need to go for that
i just pushed each pawn
and one goal is to queen trade
and black avoids the queen trade i start
winning pawns
okay much cleaner again
need games like that where i'm just
up on time in control
[Music]
yeah taking on g5 may have been possible
but
a type of thing i could have thought
about for like a minute and decide not
to play so
just had to make a
intuitive decision
[Music]
okay no stafford play some
more reputable opening playing time on
off
let's see what my opponents ooh g4
um
i'll admit i don't know so much theory
here i know this is like a trend though
like caruana did something kind of
similar to a report
at the candidates
means some kind of bishop b4
and there's some pressure here
yeah bishop d4 i'm thinking f6
i could also
maybe sack the pawn
and there's also knight f6 which is
interesting
um
shouldn't be taking too much time
let's just allow for e5
g5 might be coming
roxy8
very tense position
if i play e5
e5 we trade
actually a really annoying position here
f5 is a move
the pawn is pinned to the bishop by my
battery
and there's a calculation takes here
bishop moves back i take
try and get in d5
looks very shaky but
that's the nature of these positions
sometimes
yeah so bishop takes i think i take with
queen
and we trade
i mean meanwhile this is ideal setup
up on time finally
i might actually be threatening e3 here
okay
wow
i think it's okay
young children close your eyes
it was about to get messy
there
oh dear
really
no
good game
that was actually a really good game i
kind of
uh kind of gave away a gift there
yeah c3 i should play d3 man
that's the nature of time scrambles
thank you spreacher skrau
or spretcher's crow
okay
more losses and wins
still time to try and come back
i'm definitely not in my best form oh
it's rebecca harris hey i'm tied with
rebecca harris who later wains
oh dear i deserve you
back mr rosen this will force me to play
quick having a good day thank you carl
32 king and jumbo 44.
taking a risk i'm trying to like reverse
the momentum though
i'm getting a nice line here
yeah so i have the bishop here a better
structure
a slight edge for white
knight t4 at some point
maybe i should have put the queen on f3
um
let's start with this
i wonder actually can i
take it with e pawn bishop a3
okay
might be threatening that five
maybe you could play now if i last move
actually
okay making up some of the time deficits
it's not easy position for black dark
squares are weak
knight is really solid on d4
i don't think f6 will be played
wow fancy i think i just take it
some d5 coming
d6 may be coming d6 d7 d8 is actually
kind of hard to stop
nice having the rook behind the passer
yeah it's really hard for black to set
up a blockade
[Music]
okay point resigns
got the berserking points
the risk paid off
trying to keep pace with rebecca harris
who was maybe somewhere
maybe already past me
playing varga okay it was working again
i feel
a new sense of confidence
opponent offline already
terrified by the london opening
or struggling with internet in mexico
c5 okay
i was looking at this recently actually
oh it's a line
i thought there's some like cooler line
to play but
like knight b5
this might be over ambitious but it
looks kind of cool
bishop e3
there's some issue with a7
also c7
we might see queen
b4 queen a5
and this already looks great for white
uh is this a free knight
it gets messy because it takes on b2
bishop c3 king f1
i'm threatening bishop b5 in the end
queen is tied down to the knight
there's knight oh knight d2 funny line
queen d2
[Music]
and then bishop b5
up a full rook here
plenty of time too
okay another relatively quick bizarre
quinn
thank you
twitrod
for the first time prime sub
hey i'm on a streak it's my first two
wins in a row
and those those are my first games
berserking too
i'm undefeated best working this
tournament
maybe i should just keep beserking
i've i've uncovered the secret to
success
okay i'm playing rebecca harris who
berserks
do i berserk back
i think i need the time odds i need some
chance
oh it's joe bava london i wonder if he
saw my match
92
okay
castle
interesting
hmm
do
[Music]
queen b7 doesn't work either
some comp though
i'm in trouble
or am i
just love that hanging
this is this is completely winning
um
there's not even any stalemate traps
unfortunately
oops what did i do resign
well played what to do i got forked at
some point
rebecca harris is really strong
[Music]
and for those that don't know
except i think everyone does know
uh yeah that was nerd ski
i got easy clapped
even though he berserked i didn't
i feel like he has a decent shot at
winning the tournament too
[Music]
still a lot of time like despite late
joining
thank you z-man
i did get a decent position from the
opening though
thank you heisenberger
and floop it
okay so i'm trying to break into the top
hundred
and trying to rebuild my streak as well
yeah there's some uh
some issues for black in this position
knight h5
let me start with this
king d7 bishop b6
meanwhile of 97 i play h3 and i give the
bishop a square to retreat
yeah black played a6 because there is
some idea to take and then win the a
pawn
so a6 is very typical
also attempting to discourage b5
but this looks really nice for white
threatening the fork
knight is almost trapped as well
we might see another f4 here
and if e3 there's knight uh d3
maybe this move first and there's also
g3
i shouldn't overthink this i mean it's
pleasant there's probably a lot of ways
to
keep an advantage
hi eric
hi i'm alan miller welcome back
i mean this is really really pleasant
bishop stays
pinning the knight to the king
not to mention there's ideas of just
winning the b-pawn
yeah the pieces work beautifully
together
and meanwhile most of black's pieces are
stuck
although yeah knight d7 is coming
king c it's very timely
i think i should retreat
not what i wanted but
i still have a decent grip
king should come to d2 very soon
it's very positional
just double on the f file
knight wants to return
bishop a7
this is a nice knockout
now take and then
light comes in with a check
do i need to take that maybe not
is just so hard for black to move in
this position
uh that song had forked
ooh clever
okay
that's a nice game relatively clean long
london opening
i mean these structures are really
difficult for black if uh especially if
they don't know what they're doing
okay
what's working
again i'm undefeated this tournament
when deserving
maybe that's why i lost to danya
i didn't berserk
okay so we have this 95 line
interesting
[Music]
not sure how much i can punish this
setup from black
it's strangely symmetrical except this
bishop is a bit stuck in
discouraging bishop a6
a very tense center
okay i think i've dropped the knight
yeah this is a really nice work to work
with too
still takes a lot of work here though
[Music]
like what's the plan
um
some g4 idea
i should be meeting
despite my time
deficit
a4 is super useful
okay
man
yeah i had to surround the king from all
sides
okay
still undefeated when berserking
back on the streak 15 points
rebecca
has 20 points and 73.
oh lost a couple games
that's what dania gets for beating me
with some karma
okay i haven't had any staffords today
uh staffer declined
this is already really pleasant for
black
we might see queen b3
or that move
takes
taking with this pawn because f4 in the
end like takes and then f4 traps of
bishop
yeah this should be fine
up two pieces
threading made in one
okay that was pleasant
that's what you get for declining the
staff right now
hey
where am i
77 let's go
i've played this opponent 12 times
before
and we have a very even score
we're gonna have a similar structure to
that previous game
[Music]
um i take
knight c3
[Music]
i remember looking at this i thought
taking works but i forget why
i think i'll just play this move first
and then this and
very similar to the previous game
actually
a little bit different
but this structure is so pleasant uh in
the london
like every london player should
kind of be aware of this and know the
basic plans
okay tying down the king
so this is pinned this is pinned
this is forked
okay that was super pleasant
pins and forks top 50 let's go
slow start but uh coming back
right behind king's crusher
did i pass danya
i may have passed
anya that's my motivation this
tournament stay ahead of danya
yeah he's in 54.
uh let's play this line
i think this is okay
there's queen h4
so f6
i should know what i'm doing here
rook p8
rook b8
i'm just trying to stay flexible
some night move
i played rook b8 so now my pawns
defended
knight c3 is a move
is there a follow-up though
i'm not seeing it
so i think a plan is to play c5
it's very hard for white to kick away
the knight
like even though this isn't technically
an outpost
okay preventing c5
27
consider taking
so i'm trying to play on both sides of
the board
we have knight versus bishop
c3 might be played actually
not too concerned about this like e4 i
think
can't defend anyway
gotta move quicker though
i gotta strike when these pieces are out
of play
hmm
wow that's a mate threat
i just worse here
i can't take i i can't take the pawn
i'm just worse here
trying to fight though b6 might uh
give me some hope
there's c3 coming at some point
but i am just down upon
[Music]
b6
a difficult position
i don't know what to do
i'm just gonna hold my ground
funny structure
ah
okay i was outplayed that game
opponent played well
so there goes my win streak had four in
a row
top 60 still
yeah tournaments like this it can be
very um
[Music]
momentum based
you really have to avoid tilting
take it one game at a time one move at a
time
have a good score against this opponent
i'm sure we've played some london's
before
uh-huh
i think uh whenever they play b6 h4 is
called for
i can take
trying to accelerate the attack get the
rook involved
may have not been a need for c3
g4 is very typical too
so we
trade h6 first
maybe
i think h6 first is okay
so there's a line like takes takes takes
takes
and the bishop's pinned
and there's prospect of mating on h7
oh and if king takes i play queen g3
with
the the fork double attack
another line is if g6 i take here first
and this this is just winning because if
takes check and if takes takes takes
queen f6 is mating
so this is like the best case scenario
in the opening that the attack just
works out
black loses instantly
so knight six is a key in between move
and at this point i don't mind the queen
trade
king is going to be stuck
can castle
why i'm losing d4
wait a minute
i don't want to lose f4 as well
[Music]
okay i have to be a little bit careful
here
roxia king f1 i think is
reasonable
[Music]
this is such a nice grip on the position
although am i losing my h-pawn
uh it still takes work
and g4 g5
can never get too relaxed
i do have
a knight g4
kind of passive but it holds on to a
very key pawn
and now there's this stare down on the c
file
[Music]
one plan is 95 and then
[Music]
create a situation where the rook is
overworked
oops
uh let's move back
g4 g5 coming if knight returns i have
some force mates
b3
be completely restrictive
so the pawns restrict the knight
lights also kind of just tie down
[Music]
and black might be in zuswan here
funnily enough
okay now my king can come in
oh
[Music]
i want to put black and zuzwang
or i just want to mate
i have to be careful not to stalemate
though
g5 is what i would play let's create the
stalemate potential
that was fun
some nice opening crap
oh i took up my watch off earlier
my watch isn't charged either
so yeah no heart rate monitor to stream
can do it for future streams
okay berserking this opponent
never lost for them
going for a stafford
opponent might know what's coming and
i'm debating
whether to go into it
okay we have this line
[Music]
so i'm playing this kind of tricky
variation
[Music]
i think knight c5
this is some theory i'm pretty sure
i mean i'm out of prep but looks
reasonable
i want to play queen g4
yeah h3 was a wise move
but i'm ready to castle and these moves
don't scare me
that kind of scares me
i guess bishop e6
i always had bishop g6 as a defensive
resource
i have to be really careful though
the queen is going on some kind of
adventure
at pawns pins so i am threatening to
take a free nevermind
to take this first
pawn is hanging
wow
oh no
quack and good luck for the tournament i
need a lot of good luck here
i think i'm just getting mated
or am i
probably
i need a lot of luck here to survive
this got bad really quickly
there there
i was just i'm just getting mated
and i'm flagging
that doesn't help at all
okay
uh let's move on from that game
e6 was a really strong move
danger levels were very low for me in
that game
hey playing castersito
i wanted to berserk back
okay
well i have time odds now
a6
playing a similar setup from that
previous game
if i take
there's also f3 there's a4
a4 first
wow
if i take
we just trade a lot
a5
um
now i just want to keep tension i think
i'll play b3
weird move but
let's see what block is up to
we trade
of 94
a pleasant looking position
b5 i think i take with the rook on b5
wow
i think i just want to shift over the a
file
[Music]
because a5 is hard to defend
time-wise boxing a lot of trouble too
and position wise
f5
wow
funny line
oh that doesn't work at all
okay
oh dear
i hung a queen but it's okay
i wanted time
got a little bit careless there
i thank you zanderbach
maybe related to benjamin bach
something for five months
63rd
playing bogdan
okay playing the same repertoire
i had played this line earlier and i got
crushed
and try and redeem myself
so the point is if the bishop takes a
seemingly free knight i play d5
and then i'll win back a piece like
bishop d3 and
uh i would fork
did i already mess this up
i think this is okay
or is it
defend
and it's probably good my king is just
in the center
queen's off the board hello there
uh rook d one's coming
hello
to mavser welcome back
so i do have rook d4
[Music]
or d4 c3
if i play king e6 we trade d5
i think i'll just give the pawn and
get the king d6
you start with this
something like rook d2
yeah i was trying to assess this
it takes q6 f4
maybe play g5 first
yeah so my king is better placed but
it takes work to actually win something
here this could end up being a draw
but i am
yeah threatening workout five
so we're approaching the halfway point
the tournament
we did have a prediction earlier um
i think a lot of people predicted i'd
finish between 50 and 100.
so i'm trying to break top 50.
ideally top 30.
king takes
a force coming
f5
hmm
really got to watch the time
i don't know who's playing for a win
though
oh we repeated three times okay
i mean yeah it should be a draw i have
the more active rook and better king but
white's just super solid so
can't complain i was a little bit down
on time too
29 points
no sign of
magnus unless who is this
this is a new name
okay playing habib
amini
i'm berserking here
london opening
and play this line
this is a gambit line
i played something similar against
tacaro recently
it's dangerous for white to walk into if
they're not prepared
so there's these ideas
rook b8 first
but am i prepared
uh b6
and a4
oh i gotta move faster
now it's getting sharp
i gotta go like full attack mode
wow
eric
what's this
oh this isn't good
okay this is something
winning the e5 pawn and then too
i'm still probably objectively worse
unfortunately
no
okay i could have gotten forked there
no
oh it's so sad
we're gonna see queen d6 checkmates
ah
i'll tell you
okay lesson learned
almost fought back there played a lot of
moves with uh
two seconds left
hey it's z nation chess
57 months welcome back
the founder of the channel
okay no more berserking
i think i've gained reading this stream
a little bit
71
97
okay going for the h4 plan again
if takes there's this move so
have you seen that newish game shotgun
king it's chess but you have a shotgun
i've heard of it i haven't played it
though
there's so many other different types of
chess games to check out these days
so i'm hitting the pawn
probably provoking f6
actually wondering if i can sack
i don't think it works but
i mean this looks really pleasant
there's a five
a five queen of four
yeah so i control the diagonal very
difficult for black to kick away this
queen
there's a plan to bring the bishop back
to
target e6
some h5 move
and not easy to stop lock from castling
by hand
takes
not even sure what the follow-up should
have been there
this is going to be a fight
my advantage is kind of faded
and black might try and repeat until i
trade queens
which i think i'll do
[Music]
i'm trying to keep the game going
[Music]
up on time
position should be roughly equal
[Music]
before
the rook on the better square
really
oh no i allowed this
okay i do have b4 which i think i'll
play
up a pawn here
c4 idea
just going after the apon
um
um
okay
uh yeah it took some work
got the job done oh goodbye zoo nation
thanks for stopping by
and subbing for 57 months
uh top 70
trying to get back on the streak
playing denise can
okay double dessert
play queen scam declined don't think
i've played one of these yet today
my
um
and go for the kingside attack
queen f3 rook a3
rook c1 bishop b4 no
what am i thinking
there should be six
vision before ideas
huh
and game time
you
hmm
oops
let's go okay
man
oh it wasn't so easy there but uh
managed to prevail
on a streak 62nd place
okay
try and uh pick up some momentum here
yeah trying to stay calm
i'll play one of these
c3
a4
one goal is to create a situation where
it's difficult for black to win
back the pawn
so i have two sets of double pawns
but the pawns are defendable
queen d3
i'm keeping things solid
yeah allowing knight takes bishop i have
to take with pawn
[Music]
a for this move
there's queen c8s
[Music]
um not seeing the follow-up
f3
doesn't work
ah that's unfortunate
uh
i spent all my time looking for ways to
save the pond but
okay life goes on
f3 may be coming
threatening g4
from down the pawn here but black has
some dark square weaknesses
how does black
prevent g4
g5 i take it
there's a3 but we trade first
interesting okay i wanted to
play bishop d3
but not happening
i guess now g5 it takes in rook t3
hitting this and this
king side's more important here
not sure what's going on here just have
to play quickly
threading made in one
or made in a few
go
king can come in maybe
okay threading made in one
it's unstoppable too
wow
nick of time
okay berserking paid off that game
let's go top 50.
been a while since i've been in the top
50.
next goal is top 30
which is
it's within reach if i win a couple more
games
now berserking i guess it did pay off
that game
barely
playing pisano or
oh i wanted i was debating whether to
berserk but now i didn't have the chance
okay we played the game earlier in this
similar line
i should show the berserk because this
line is uh
is pleasant for white
okay i'm gonna go for the same
idea
yeah there's rook a7 but i'm already
threatening b5
does that work
it might actually work well i think i've
seen this tactic before
it takes
i should take your fur
no
wow
[Music]
take
take
i think i just want to keep pieces on
the board
like i think i'll just play this move in
key 2 rook c1
[Music]
and just play down the pawn but i have
the bishop here
knight a5
a clever play from black
b6 is a move wonder can i
go in deep idea knight t6 even bishop d6
uh
i have to be really careful here
the knight is very precarious
okay so we could trade
keep the bishop here
trying to calculate this line takes
takes
[Music]
i'll play brook c6 rook d6 is e5
not seeing how it works let's play g4
first
and time is on my side
can you have five vision d3 checkmates
okay i think i'm safe now
i'm i missed maiden one ah i missed a
rosin trophy i could play d7 checkmate
with a pawn
what to do
still one on time
41st place
just over an hour left
so top 30 is
about five points away
playing drop stone very strong player
i'm not going berserk
i'll play one of
these i'm gonna play a dragon
but it's a dragon dwarf
i don't think i've seen bishop d3 before
i think you polly me
appreciate the bits
i have this move
do this and this
i want to sack on
actually it might be okay
the problem is b2 is loose so if queen
g2 i trade and win b2
meanwhile i am threatening maiden 2.
i mean there there there
there's f4
i'm gonna start with this
where's the mate
i do have this is actually kind of
simple
oh this made in three
oh it's a cool main three
so i deflect the pawn away
and then check and then here and then
meet
okay oh those cool mates
nice uh shish kebab
okay
also thank you paulie gifting to bali
i think it was a good choice not to
berserk just try and
win over the board
35 points or 35th place 47 points
leader has 91.
playing zuber
another strong player
has a plus score against me
still over an hour left
knight c6
i'll play this line
e4
some weird like alakine
not quite an alkyne though what we call
this
i'm fresh opening i've never looked at
this position before
h4h5 ideas
black having similar ideas
d6
very tempting but
i'm better off just playing h4
hmm
trying to chase the bishop back
to be inside the pawn chain
ah b5 another concern
bishop b5
i think it makes some sense actually
um
and the eventual plan is to break with
c5
i have six i think i play knight g5
oh black one's a pawn
[Music]
i could win h5
or can i maybe i can't
hmm
take first and just g3
down the pawn but have more space
and light wants to come to f5
i think i have to play b5 not the move i
wanted to play but
um
f4
just trying to hold my ground
might win the a pawn actually
ah
i'm just losing
well played
got to an endgame equal material
although
yeah i probably chose the wrong plan
but already maybe it's too late
what to do
uh still top 40.
playing castro sito again
who
i beat earlier
because
did i just work back i forget
i'm not because working back though
trying to gain some points
uh okay let's play this line
queen c8 i think is some theory
[Music]
i'll admit i don't know this so well
though
i've probably already butchered this
but maybe it's okay
knight before
okay
confusing position
[Music]
having a hard time like understanding
what's going on here
i think it's okay though
i'm probably a little bit worse
there's some queen c8
i've rooked e8 actually nah let's see
five pawn is weak
that might be much worse actually
i'm trying to play this move
hmm
okay
time scramble time
that
okay i feel a little bit dirty about
that
but that's the nature of no increment
chess
oh
i mean i was worse for most of that game
but i just had to keep surviving
surviving
um
that's the nature of these time
scrambles too
i've been a victim of that many times
okay 40 uh 40th place
49 points
okay new sense of confidence
play one of these
more of a bullet game now
the night before
might be knight before here
really
rook p1 ideas
it looks like i'm getting muted i don't
see it
that's terrifying though
d7
it's hard to find a move for white
actually
um
yeah white's king is less safe than my
king now
okay
uh that was a scary game i could have
easily lost that i think
but uh managed to win
got the berserking points too
oh playing fidel okay good friend of
mine we've played before
playing some kind of slav type thing
playing one of these
yeah gambling a bit
so i'm down the pawn but i think there's
full comp
oh this cool idea takes takes on the
rook h5
the g pawn is pinned to the h pawn
there's queen a4 counter-attacking
i'm actually wondering if i could sock
the rook
play rook h5 anyway
i think it works
oh there's that move i have this move
uh not so simple now
that
okay
oh
it's hard to pre-move uh as black bear
with just the king all these queen
checks
i mean he tried to throw all these spike
checks to flag me
that was a close one
let's go top 30 25th place
okay i don't mind uh nop is working i
have to cool down from that last game
we have this london line
i played this earlier
something similar earlier
rook c8
and queen v6 wait
queen c7
i think i can just castle
because there's an issue with the pin
and now ruxiate
hello
hello
some f6 idea
i got the chance i should take the
bishop
it's a free pawn
93
hmm
hitting this and this
rook d3i of this move
and that's very restricted
or how to make progress
i take that
thanks for the raid benjamin bach
welcome back
you're just joining i'm trying to not
lose
tricky position
this is a potential idea
[Music]
i mean h7 is defended
now this move
starting mate
i forgot my rooks hanging but so white's
work is hanging in that line too
still throwing meat
there we go
let's go okay
got the job done
over 2600 let's go that was the goal for
this stream
yeah shout out to bach
if you're just joining this is a title
blitz arena
i had a rocky start but now i'm uh in
22nd place
um
yeah still 40 minutes ago so still gotta
stay focused
take it one game at a time
one move at a time
a lot of opponents are working so
i don't mind getting time odds
place some time on of like bishop's
already misplaced
oh the white's trying to justify it
d5 probably coming
doh i hung upon
oh okay
it should be fine though
all right it's still playable at least
and treat this as a gambit
accepting double pawns i want to open
the g file
really
play g5
we trade
and then
h5 let's try this
e6 is vulnerable
i think it's okay oh wait no i don't
have an h5
that's probably too risky to take
queen sees no queen c6 doesn't work
we trade
maybe just castling
now i am starting to take
squares are weak
that e4 is coming
i'm queen here
can we trade
i don't think i can avoid it
queen b5
well
um
you
no stalemate trick for me
ah good game
okay
that's a close one
i got outplayed there
lost upon in the opening
thank you awkward knight
still top 30 61 tournament points
tube off this is dubois i think leading
the tournament
uh i'll do this
so c6 i take on d6
it's actually kind of
awkward for lock
that's a move
g4 idea
and b4 is kind of risky but it's
interesting
okay i'm winning the pawn i think almost
oh no my knight
okay
wow
almost didn't win that
forgot the w 23rd place
yeah very shaky conversion
but that's the nature of some of these
time scrambles
okay half hour left
castor cito again
caster sito has beserched twice against
me
last few games
and i've i've won both times
what's up
um
oh we had that nice game
was it
what was the game i forget
okay i'll play one of these again
have a dragon type thing
thank you gary thank you ash no one
going for the double fiend keto
knight c5 ideas
playing knight before
a pawn can't move backwards
i probably rook c8
okay
not sure what to do
rookie it's kind of just a
nothing move it does defend e7
uh thanks for the raid whoever you are
oh it's a oh it's a trap kind of thing
thank you oh thank you supersede
appreciate the raid
yeah if you're just joining i'm trying
to stay extra focused
it's a title arena
um
yeah shout out to supersede
gonna
[Music]
try and convert the material advantage
here
oh okay that's one way of converting
opponent just resigns
so getting the battery of caster seat of
this tournament
three wins
so 23rd place 66 points
dubois running away with it there are
prizes for top five but i'm very far
away from fifth place
playing this opponent again who i
recently beat in that crazy time
scramble
was opening that game
oh i was white that's from london
uh
i don't want a berserk i hope that's
okay
what is nike one
wait this is just an english
yeah this is english now
opponent lost some tempe in the opening
i have to be careful bishop g5
okay going for some transformation
c3 we trade
this looks reasonable c4 might be played
put the queen on c5
and go for some e3 move
some queen a3 move
bishop should be here probably
okay
i actually have to be really careful
here
maybe f6
connect four
yeah this looks great
white was trying to attack on the king's
side but now i'm the one attacking
[Music]
okay let's take a pawn
okay
got the job done
where am i
hey there i am top 20 let's go
23 minutes
left games will probably be getting
harder
yeah playing 2900 level player
i don't think i've ever been a 2900
level player
i was ready for bishop e7 but
not happening this game
[Music]
it does happen just not hanging a bishop
queen h3
i have been magnus but that's some
bullet
um
play what to play
and bishop d392
probably e4 very soon
even right now
trying to be solid
e5 may be coming
c6 knight c5
15 going on 50 hands down my favorite
chess player
thank you for everything thank you
uh bishop c4 we trade
oh looks promising
ve5 included
if castling i can take in
tactics although there is bishop d7
should d7 right away
e5
a lot of resources here
take
g4
hitting the pawn
okay
have e5
f4
um
am i doing
completely botched this
uh such a good position earlier too
[Music]
uh
what to do
oh that was rough
such a good position to
just kind of let things slip towards the
end
a couple of bad moments
okay 21st place life goes on
in front of rockstar
oh it's mid lane
okay playing lancelot
okay
some tilt
i'm gonna play this line
i think this is already like not so
great for whites
this is a new kind of very
lesser-known gambit against english
i've been playing a little bit online
actually prepared for levy
g4 is a nice square
uh
[Music]
to take
this is not good for me
neutralize a file first
barely holding on
no
ah
i was trying to set it up too
oh it's so sad
good game though
thank you johan senator
lifting to dr spod
oh what to do
it's hard playing so much chess
back to back to back
playing hacking kid
dobavo london time
uh
[Music]
this looks good
maybe maybe it's just playable for both
sides
okay got some end game or some queenless
middle game
we train
oh
no okay not over though
god got a bishop here
um
not my proudest game
any tricks there's one trick
king takes pawns stalemate
i just set it up
okay i resign
oh it's rough okay still top 30. i think
the the goal is to finish top 30 and
above 2600
uh nobody's working this game
try and cut the losses
uh we'll play one of these
try and be aggressive here
b1
so this is a more kind of positional job
london
maneuver the queen to g3
okay we could queen train
going for f3
yeah another middle game grind
i have to be careful
[Music]
in knight f5 i have to take it
bishop f5
wait a minute how do i deal with this
am i losing a pawn
i don't see how to not lose a pawn
takes
rookie two
like i'm not in time
that's unfortunate
i think i have to play like rookie two
and just lose h pawn
and bishop five was a good move
unless
oh it's really close to working g3
[Music]
no it doesn't work
okay down the pawn
i go for e4
trying to trap the knight
threatening g3
that seems wrong to go for e4 when i'm
down the pawn but
i feel like this is a decent try
although okay now i have this move
threatening knight c4
i'm still probably worse somehow but
this isn't so bad
especially if a5 falls
we trade rooks and if a5 falls in
these pawns could fall
so i think rook a8
really
ah um
very clever
what's going on here
gotta move quicker
this should just be a draw
no
no
i didn't leave myself with enough time
ah
that's so sad
i think i got too relaxed towards the
end too
[Music]
this is gonna be close actually
um
because there was a prediction uh
[Music]
that
will be fulfilled soon
as a question can i stay within the top
30
oh i'm playing donya okay no berserking
so one of these
oh no
already messed up
i'll try and stay alive though
hmm
really does that work
i can't even take that
hmm
it takes
yeah we'll play
nice end game technique
though pairings are closed hey i'm still
top 30.
where'd tanya finish
wow okay at least i kind of helped him
uh
did i help him no he was going gonna
finish in second anyway
such a big gap between him and portnik
uh yeah nice job dania lee joining the
tournament
finishing second to dubov
uh
beating me twice
winning winning 250 dollars not bad
dupont winning 500.
anyway uh yeah that was that was fun
wait for the tournament to officially
finish
thank you flame eyes
also thanks everyone earlier who maybe i
didn't acknowledge
the cooper man 88 supersede gary gifting
[Music]
star mitzi was here gifting to mike
coker
did i help duboff oh maybe i helped duba
by slowing down danya
oops
okay
so i finished in
25. better result than usual
finished slightly below 2600 i mean
i finished with five losses
for out of steam towards the end
but uh
i mean i was like covering around 20 at
some point
it was definitely my one of my best
total arenas in recent memory
despite some of the rocky games at the
start
so only eight percent of people
or eight percent of the channel points
wagered
were um
[Music]
predicting top 30.